Moving into a completely new era of
history,
and I describe it in two ways,
it's the end of the era of western
domination of world history,
but I hasten to add it's not the end of
the West.
The West will remain single strongest
civilization for long,
long time to come,
but it can no longer dominate the world
and the way it has for the last 200
years and the second aspect of this new
era.
Of course it's the return of Asia and
while the return of Asia seems rather
abnormal.
Now actually if you look at not the last
200 years,
but look at the last 2000 years,
the two largest economies of the world
have consistently been China and India.
So if China and India become,
once again the Rogers economies,
as everyone predicts in the 21st
century,
it will clearly be returned to know and
so we shouldn't be surprised.
It's going to happen.